this is a production of cornell
university
so welcome everybody uh we have a really
exciting panel discussion today on the
topic
of gsg emissions from agriculture as it
pertains also to carbon sequestration
try to bound this uh this topic a little
bit by
the consideration of what's really
possible and
essentially looking back in
retrospective mode
to see sort of what's changed over the
last
decade uh what we've learned and
uh having some critical thoughts about
how we how we move forward
so um you know we have a really
fantastic panel here today and cornell
has the advantage of having global
expertise and global carbon cycling
atmospheric dynamics
all the way down to soil scientists who
work
both at the fundamental level but also
on agronomic management options
and we have the good fortune of having
four of our
really global leaders in this area join
us today for
the panel uh we have natalie montwald
who's the
irving border church professor in rich
and atmospheric sciences
we have peter woodbury who is a senior
research associate in soil and crop
sciences within sips
we have dominic wolfe who's also a
senior research associate
uh in the soil and crop sciences and
sips and we have johannes lehmann who's
the liberty high baylor
bailey professor also in soil crop
sciences so
we have a really fantastic panel uh
today
um i should say that this is
really timely to have this you know you
can't
you can't go 30 seconds if you're paying
attention to
the the scientific media mass media on
these things without
a mention of regenerative agriculture or
the potential role for
agriculture to reduce net ghg emissions
but there's a lot of a contention around
how we get there
and the the panel today is meant to to
point us in that direction
the way it will go is that we're gonna
have uh four lightning talks in the
order that i
introduced the speakers then we're gonna
pivot to
a panel discussion that will take us to
about 120
and and then the final 10 minutes or so
will be open questions from the audience
so
please keep those uh keep those in your
pocket type them in the chat if you have
to go
and we'll pivot to them at the end of
the session today
uh so with no further ado i think that
dominic you're
in the lead on transitioning between
slides
and everyone else please make sure that
your mics are muted
and away we go thank you to the panel
for applying this together
well thank you ender for moderating i
think i'm up next here since my slide is
on here and uh
um what i want to emphasize um you know
i'm not a soil scientist
what i want to emphasize is really what
do we need to do to meet the low carbon
targets
so i'm natalie mahowald i'm not going to
talk about my own personal work
with earth system science or climate
models i'm really just going to
present the ipcc intergovernmental panel
on climate change
results here and the context for soil
sequestration
what do we need to do to meet the low
carbon targets
one really important point that i find
that a lot of people don't really
understand
is climate change has really long time
skills and that's really what we're
trying to get after
so um on this slide this is a classic
climate change kind of slide where we
start you know the
x-axis is 1850 out to 2100 here in the
middle or
2300 to the right so this is the kind of
view i have of the world these really
long time scales
um on the y-axis that's the temperature
change and you can see in octo 2005 for
this particular plot from the last ipcc
assessment report
that's the historical time series and
right now we're at a crossroads where
we can go on the red trajectory which
would be business as usual
which you know 2100 might be 4 degrees c
2308 degrees or more c
versus if we act right now and we
completely change
our economy and start sequestering
carbon as much as possible that's this
lowest blue line
um so really we're acting now to have an
impact
at 2100 or later so it's a really
difficult problem for politicians to get
their head around but also for humans to
get their head around but
it's really important to understand
climate change has a really
long time scale next slide
the the other point to make is that it
is
the cumulative co2 emissions which is on
the x-axis here
um that linearly relates to the
temperature anomaly relative
uh to pre-industrial and there's a
little bit of
noise up and down in this you can see um
you know from short-lived gases like
methane or aerosols or
exactly the trajectory but almost all
this is co2 emissions are dominating now
nitrous oxide emissions also have a
really long lifetime so
they could also be included here but are
much much smaller in magnitude
but the reason we only think about the
cumulative co2 is because of the
really long lifetime of co2 which is
thousands of years
and how much co2 we emit okay and the
really important thing to understand
is that until our anthropogenic net
anthropogenic co2 emissions go to zero
we will continue to have climate change
under the paris agreement we're going
for three or three and a half degrees
yeah um who's going to cause most of our
climate change
um it's developing countries if they use
our pathway
i mean that's how we got here to our
wealth
um and our uh lifestyle is by emitting a
lot of co2
and developing countries of course want
to have our lifestyle
why wouldn't they and they want to have
our long lifetimes with really good
health care well
okay maybe we don't have that but we
have better health care
um and an incredible thing is is
happening right now or what's before
covet is we might actually be able to
eradicate
extreme poverty by 2030 and we have the
sustainable development goals
and you can see this in this slide again
going from 1820 to 2015 that the number
of people in extreme poverty has
actually gone down over the last 30
years so this is
incredible this would be great if this
happened but the bad part is is right
now they're following our development
pathway
which is the cheap way to do it which
has emitted a lot of co2
so this is the real dilemma it's climate
change versus development for
a lot of the people on this planet and
that makes it really really hard
next slide so what do we need to do
to meet the low climate carbon targets
given that developing countries want to
develop
well here again is one of these long
time series plots but but what we have
to do
on the y-axis here is our co2 emissions
per year
we have to stop emitting from fossil
fuel sources here
and turn our economy around so that
we're not using so much co2
not using fossil fuels using renewables
and we can switch to low-carbon energy
sources right away
and i think the developed countries need
to lead on this
with solar and wind and developing the
battery technology
we also need to cut the cut energy
demand we need to change our behavior to
reach any of these low carbon targets
and we need to develop new technologies
there's quite a bit of co2
emissions that we don't have substitutes
for we solar and wind aren't substitutes
for them
but really importantly that i think a
lot of people don't understand is
because the developing countries are
developing right now
and because uh the co2 emissions are
are so difficult to substitute for some
things
we have to develop carbon dioxide
removal techniques and i think that
the recent ipcc reports have made this
so abundantly clear
and the technologically easiest of the
land-based natural methods that we're
going to talk about today
and and how how good are they and how
useful are they
but we're probably also going to need
tecla technological methods but
the really important thing to understand
is that carbon dioxide removal
is going to be necessary for any of our
carbon targets
thank you
hi i'm peter woodbury i'm gonna i have
the next section
of the of our short presentations here
next slide please
so today we're talking about carbon
sequestration in
agriculture focusing mostly on soil
carbon
sequestration but i want to flip the
script for a moment
and say as many of you know if you've
been involved with agriculture there are
many reasons to add organic matter or
carbon to soil
in fact greenhouse gas mitigation
may not be anywhere near the top of most
people's lists for the reasons to do so
so we're talking about improving soil
health or soil quality
reducing erosion reducing compaction
improving the infiltration of the soil
for for water improving drainage
and increasing water holding capacity
these are among many
many functions that can improve with
improved soil health
due to in additions of organic matter
another important thing is maintaining
or increasing
crop yields and that's important
obviously for many reasons but in the
in the climate change context it's
important because of leakage
so the idea being
if we can have increased
sustainable intensification and
increased crop production on the lands
that we have
through both yield increases and
through intensification of cropping
cycles so having
having crops on the land more of the
time
we reduce the pressure globally and
regionally
to cut down forests to to have new crop
land available
so that's that's the connection here
between
uh crop yield and and production
and greenhouse gas mitigation
and then of course we're here today to
talk about sequestering carbon
and we're going to talk about how that's
temporary that if you can add carbon to
the soil it can also be lost again
and as we just heard we have a very
long-term problem in climate change so
we need
long-term solutions if we're putting
carbon in the soil
we need it to stay there next slide
please
this is just an example of
another way to think about this leakage
idea
and this is showing that as grass yield
increases the greenhouse gas emissions
per unit of of yield per ton of grass
production decreases this wouldn't be a
decrease
on the area of crop land so any
greenhouse gas benefit of this would
have to be this idea of avoiding leakage
next slide please
so one topic that's discussed frequently
in terms of agricultural
soil carbon is reducing tillage
and this is indeed possible to reduce or
eliminate tillage in many systems
the issue is that the soil carbon that's
added can
easily be lost again if tillage
increases
next slide
there's also a lot of discussion of of
cover cropping in
in the u.s and some other places but i'd
like to focus instead on
on double cropping so again this is the
idea of sustainable intensification
by increasing the the number of crops in
a cropping cycle
so in new york state that might mean
adding a
a winter a double crop
over the winter to what's normally a
single crop system
and again we get these same benefits of
adding organic matter to soil
we also might be able to to scavenge and
reduce some nutrient loss
and again we can increase soil carbon
next slide please
so much as i love soil i also love trees
and i want to mention them because
storing soil carbon is not only
temporary it's also hard to measure
and verify so if we want to know whether
a benefit's occurring
it's quite challenging trees are easier
to
see they can be visually assessed
and you can assess the amount of carbon
with a limited number of measurements of
the trees
and and calculate calculating the amount
of carbon sequestration
so another possibility for carbon
sequestration in agriculture in addition
to soils is adding trees
one way or another to agricultural
systems this is an example
in new york state of a silver pasture
so it's grazing livestock but also
produce growing fence posts
to keep the livestock contained and
growing
black walnuts as a longer term crop so
it's a
cropping system that has livestock
tree production grazing
and also is sequestering carbon in the
trees there are many other ways to add
trees to
agricultural landscapes and many of
these
have multiple benefits in addition to
carbon sequestration
next slide please
so this is my final slide for for my
section
and this is from a paper on
on natural climate solutions
globally and it's just a selection of
some of the pathways from this
publication
you're going to hear more about biochar
today
conservation agriculture is what is
roughly speaking also regenerative
agriculture so these would be
practices such as as
cover cropping and reduced tillage
and there are two bars here one for
peatland restoration and one for avoided
peatland impa
impacts and of course this is
for the very high carbon soils that have
the potential
to lose a great deal of carbon on an
area basis
so they deserve special attention
and trees in cropland this was just a
limited
choice of growing alleys of trees among
among crop fields so there's additional
opportunities that are not shown here
the largest bars are avoided forest
conversion and reforestation
and why am i showing those when our
topic is agriculture
the reason is because the only way that
these
can be implemented is by increasing
agricultural production on current
agricultural lands so this is taking
low quality land out of grazing a small
fraction about four percent globally
and replanting it in trees that's the
reforestation
that requires that we produce the
livestock more efficiently
on a smaller amount of land so
agriculture
improved production
is the way that we can achieve both of
these
forest pathways thanks very much
okay thank you peter um so yeah
um i'm also going to talk a little bit
about soil carbon sequestration
um like so if peter's mentioned that
there are
many reasons apart from climate change
why we might want to do it it provides a
lot of benefits
but i'm going to focus on in this little
talk about
its climate impacts and i think natalie
set it up nicely with um
the point about the fact that we really
need to think in terms of long-term
temperature changes
depend on your overall carbon budget so
it's your
it's the net amount of co2
emitted or removed from the atmosphere
that will determine your long-term
uh temperature rise so with that in mind
how much can we actually store in soils
i mean there's
it's hard to sort of open a newspaper or
anything these days without seeing
someone talking about how massive the
potential is
uh here's one uh modeling study i could
have used others i use this one because
it's a recent
study myself johannes and some other
collaborators have
just produced which will be available on
our website soon
so we took the ipcc model um and
ran it globally to see if we
on cropland for example on every piece
of cropland in the world
if we did all we could do in terms of
increasing organic matter inputs and in
terms of reducing soil disturbance and
no-till
i kind of thing on grasslands if we
managed all of our grasslands so that we
brought them up to
native grassland quality um with a lot
of carbon stored in them
so there's a lot of degraded crust
glands where that could be reversed
the third panel that we're called
rewilding is if what would
just as a thought exercise in a sense to
see what is the ultimate potential
if we removed all humans from the planet
and allowed all of our agricultural
lands to go back to their native
natural condition how much carbon would
that store
and the bottom side i'm probably not
spent too much time concentrating on it
just to be aware that
of course it can go the other direction
if we continue to degrade our
agricultural lands as we have been
we could lose up to over 100 petagrams
of carbon
that's more now a pentagram of carbon
say was a billion tons i mean these
sound like massive numbers and they're
driving a lot of
interest potentially this these are the
projections to 30 centimeters
if you look at the whole sole depth down
to two meters it could be maybe three
times that
um but these are these give you a sense
of just what scale
we could do in terms of drawing down
carbon is that a lot though
well we have to reflect on just how
large
the climate change problem is that we're
dealing we really have an emissions
problem that we need to tackle at the
moment with
its average emissions over the last
decade have been close to
11 uh petrograms of carbon
as co2 a year so
if we stored as much carbon as we could
in the world's croplands
that would avoid roughly 16 months of
current emissions
and that's only co2 that's not even our
other greenhouse gas emissions
or in grasslands 14 months of co2
removing all humans from the
planet is maybe three and a half three
and a third years
if we talk about uh the full depth of
profile maybe a decade of emissions
that we could be stored i think these um
numbers are quite
um they give us pause to actually
reflect on
the fact that we need to focus on
emissions with
most urgency because any delay in
reducing emissions can
quickly within a matter of months out do
anything that we could achieve over a
century in terms of ambitious
programs of soil carbon sequestration in
agriculture
so reducing emissions is absolutely
imperative
and this is if you like icing on the
cake as natalie mentioned we need to
draw down
we aren't going to get to a stable um
habitable climate without
also removing missions but we really
need to be
cognizant of just what soul carbon
sequestration could achieve in that
regard
so i'd also like to make the point that
soil carbon sinks are actually quite a
risky place to put in
carbon peter mentioned this as well
anything that you put into the soils
if you return to business as usual
practices can be lost again
um and in fact it's not simply that
there's a risk
of return to business as usual but the
more soil organic carbon you put in the
soils
if you put it there is solar organic
matter that soil organic matter also
contains
other nutrients notably phosphorus and
nitrogen but
others as well which historically
farmers have accessed these nutrients by
tilling their solar organic matter and
turning it into
plant food and the more you build up
again in fact the more you increase the
incentives to actually reverse some of
these gains that you had so
it's not only risky because we might
stop but it's risky because people may
actually want to stop
um it's also risky because it's um
these incentives to reverse could i
actually play out in a farmer's
favor if they decided to reverse any
gains and they get paid again just
quite carbon in the same land also it's
risky in the sense that
there will be huge incentives to do
things like moving carbon from one place
to another so for example if you're
getting paid carbon credits with soy
carbon
you only put into your into that carbon
scheme the land that is storing it but
you
build soil carbon that place by moving
your crop residues your minerals and
something else from other places
you get paid to store carbon you've
actually relocated and you haven't
actually
put anything new into the system
just the third thing i'd like to
highlight in terms of things we need to
be careful about with solar organic
carbon as a sink
is that it's really just not a very
efficient way of using biomass
um so in terms of if you add
a ton of uh carbon in the form of
biomass into your soils
after a hundred years around a percent
of that might be left it depends
depending on your climate and
the quality of that of the biomass
itself how long the exact percentage
but it's a very small fraction of that
carbon bromine most of it will be
respired by microbes over the course of
that century
and and even more into the future
whereas if
we took the same biomass converted to
biochar about 40
of that carbon would remain after 100
years in the biochar plus we can get
other benefits from things like avoiding
nitrous oxide emissions from soils
and producing co-producing energy with
at the same time
surface fossil fuels if we only burn
that
biomass to make bioenergy we could
offset a lot of fossil fuels we don't
get any carbon storage but the
mitigation potential is still very much
larger than adding that by mass to soils
and it's expensive to do but in terms of
the
most efficient way we know of really to
use that biomass at the moment
is if we uh both store most of that
carbon by pumping underground in the
form of co2
and release energy while converting it
to co2 which can also
um fossil fuels we can get a very much
more efficient use of that same biomass
so it's economists
often think in terms of something they
call an opportunity cost
so if we if we want to say that building
solar cardiac carbon is a net gain for
the
climate that really depends on what we
see as being the
alternative the best alternative and the
best alternative if we're just
squandering that carbon rather than
solar carbon yes of course it's again
but if we look at it relative to the
other ways you might use that carbon
more efficiently in fact it's a
detriment
it's a loss to a climate mitigation
because you've squandered away the
opportunity to do very much
more with that same carbon uh finally
just one last slide i want to finish on
a more positive note
is that soil carbon is not just saw
organic carbon
so biochar obviously very much more
stable although
it's expensive to make um so we needed
carbon price to actually drive that
but because it's much more stable we can
build up stocks very much
more quickly and we can
we know that they will be there for very
much longer and
another on the right hand side enhanced
weathering so if we're looking at the
inorganic carbon cycle
adding basic rocks uh ground up to
agricultural soils
they react with carbon dioxide dissolved
in groundwater
to uh in the weathering reaction to
produce carbonates and bicarbonates
which then
store the carbon in in inorganic for
form
and there is a very large global
potential to do those
storing that carbon safely away long
term and
combating ocean acidification at the
same time
thank you i'll pass over to johannes now
thank you dominic um yeah
thanks for organizing uh andy and and
natalie for steering us into this and
setting us up
i would like to give you some messages
first
dominic if you give me the next slide um
just some some random maybe seemingly
random sound bites
um that i want to close this this first
round robin
uh one is that there's a big difference
between
the actual removal so the carbon that's
sequestered and greenhouse gas emission
reductions and
and there might be trade-offs um and
i'll show you some some
slides about that and of course there's
food production
also as as peter so correctly mentioned
um
and that might be what the farmer is all
after uh whereas
maybe society and policy making is is
after the others as well
and there might be trade-offs equally
but also some synergies
but not always synergies uh there's
a really a large controversy around
achievable targets and you might have
heard about the 4 per ml initiative
it's really important and that starts to
be
more of the vernacular on the street so
to speak
that these goals being more aspirational
and inspirational that than actually
uh goals that that can be achieved at
any place
and the focus shifting more from
from the actual carbon accrual to soil
health benefits
when looking at at the organic carbon
it's really
not about locked away but the
persistence is a as a result of
functional complexity that is
needed and that needs constant care
rather than a one-time sequestration
there's spatial
questions that that are still ignored
and i'll show you something and
dominic just mentioned inorganic carbon
sequestration um and i show you no
slides about that because there is not
very much to be shown about it and
but that we really need to figure this
out as well and
and and uh and fold it into this
this discussion so now here here's why i
tell you this
um in the next slide uh
so the the the four per ml uh paris
accord
was really a political move and has has
made a world of difference
you might be very very critical and you
should be
um and there was a [ __ ] storm storm of
of a publication flurry at some point
that has died down luckily a little bit
um
uh but uh it it was a world of
difference for somebody like me who
went to the un conventions and political
meetings
um for now 15 years or so
or if you talked about soil carbon in
the 2000s everybody would laugh you out
of the room
and now soul carbon even natalie talks
about soil organic carbon
right so so even atmospheric scientists
are talking about soil organic carbon
now
um which is really a massive change from
10 15 years ago
the 4 per ml is really just a
calculation
of thinking through what is the net
emissions
between what we have in an emissions
um from fossil fuel uh emissions versus
the uh uptake in oceans and land and
and the missing one to balance the
budget at the time
uh was about equating two four per ml of
soil carbon stock so that's that's
really all there was no
further thinking um and uh and and
but i think that there's no it
it started uh accelerating a discussion
that puts more fine points on what's
actually achievable
the next slide um the
the the concept of uh why do we have
organic carbon in soil has fundamentally
changed what
it looks like uh has fundamentally
changed over the last decade or so
um from recalcitrance uh at that point
of so-called humic substances and humus
uh to
a much more nuanced understanding
of decomposition and mineralization
phenomena in the soil the
the importance of mineral stabilization
and aggregate stabilization of organic
carbon
and more uh the importance of
what's called functional complexity
of the pore structures the temporal
dynamics
and the diversity of organic matter in
soil
which all relates and says that we need
to
think about this as an ecosystem the
soil um and
we we to achieve greater persistence we
really need to manage that entire
ecosystem
uh and that that doesn't mean we can put
something in and forget about it um
it's really that that constant care
versus one-time sequestration that
that's that's how we need to think about
soil carbon
think about soil carbon and the the
dichotomy
or synergy of greenhouse gas emission
reductions and
and uh green and soil carbon accrual and
actual cdr uh carbon dioxide removal
from the atmosphere
here illustrated with biochar systems
that
have multiple moving parts as you can
see
introducing pyrolysis in biochar into an
agro ecosystem means that we can
offset fossil fuels due to
biomass fuels uh that
reduces fossil fuel emissions the
um transformation of an easily
decomposing
material into something that's biochar
will will uh reduce emissions
of that material but then also the
biochar has
can have effects on carbon that's
already in the soil
other greenhouse gases methane and
nitrous oxide and
of course increase or change
sometimes decrease crop production and
lead to
additional or less photosynthesis so
there are you already see the
the the story between cdr and ghg
emission reductions is is not a
straightforward one but there are
systems such as biochar and the others
as well
where all of those play a role um and
are
potentially synergistic if we're
increasing soil health and increasing
photosynthesis or antagonistic as i will
show
in the next slides um so we can look at
in the next slide um the the
relationship between
systems greenhouse gas emission
interactions here on the x-axis
versus actual soil carbon accrual cdr
um on the y-axis and plot some of the
major and and divergent um uh or
very different strategies cropland
management is really
um a system where we manage inherent
carbon
uh such as through less tillage or
growing more diverse crops and
crop residue management and so on but
you're dealing with
with carbon that's already in the system
whereas biochar
is potentially a a lateral and most
often a lateral transfer
of carbon and input um and and
behaves therefore very different whereas
restored wetland uh
is a system where you're reducing
the the output more than increasing the
input
and and you see that the the
relationship between
system greenhouse gas emissions uh
reductions and and so a carbon accrual
uh look very different whereas biochar
has
has um uh tilts more towards a greater
uh greenhouse gas emission reduction at
about the same
carbon accrual um restored wetland is
is sort of on the other side um that
also is an interesting
way to look at it in the on the next
slide if you um
plot the uh the soil carbon accrual so
more carbon sequestration in soils
against food production
um and and there you see very clearly
you know in most restored wetlands we
would assume that we're displacing
wetlands with with agriculture
um if if it happened at all and
and therefore we typically see a
reduction in food production and a
negative
relationship whereas with cropland
management we probably
would always uh very often assume that
we have
more yield with more carbon and soil
although it plateaus at some point
but um that there might be a negative
relationship between those two
as well whereas in biochar with adding
carbon we're probably
in most cases increase although probably
not linearly
probably asymptotic increase yields and
and
and food production whereas with with
fertilizer we
we probably increase um food production
but
in many cases um not accrue more carbon
although
there's there's um interesting debates
about that
uh to close i want to make the point
about the spatial redistribution
um of of resources and carbon and
nutrients
uh and that hasn't been done really at
all um
uh we we sort of recognized that this is
a landscape issue
um that carbon is moving around the
landscape and can be allocated in
different areas especially if we're
talking about waste biomass
especially if we're talking about
nutrient rich here an example from pyrol
from poultry litter and the conversion
with thermochemical
techniques um the example of the state
of georgia in the u.s
where uh the phosphorus resources with
poultry
are very differently distributed in the
state than
the phosphorus demands and therefore the
biochar needs
and you can find different optima
between
emission reductions profit and
greenhouse and and total carbon dioxide
sequestration
so you would you would plan your
conversions and your collection stations
across the state very very differently
if you would prioritize profit
versus greenhouse gas emission
reductions uh versus carbon
sequestration uh so those analysis have
done only been incipiently
and and they certainly lead both to
opportunities for
for trade-offs um uh and and for
some synergies um but that's that's
really at the start of it only
well that was it from me thank you very
much
thank you so much johannes and peter
dominic and natalie
um we're going to pivot now to asking a
couple of of questions from my side to
the panel
we'll kind of try to keep that short so
that we at least have five to ten
minutes for the
the audience to chime in but to the
panel i'd like to ask you first
um what you think are some potential
game changers
in land use based strategies for ghg
mitigation
that could be prioritized by the donor
communities private companies and also
younger scientists
to perspectives on that
well this is peter out okay go ahead go
ahead dominic
okay i mean we've well i think we've
mentioned a couple of potential game
changes already the talks i won't go on
again about the inorganic carbon and
things like that but a couple of things
that we could add really are one is
recognizing that in green that the
greenhouse gas emission profile from
agriculture is
not is more about nitrous oxide than it
is about the carbon story
and the potentials there are massive now
most
of that is focusing on the fact that um
about 45 percent of nitrogen that we add
to fields end up in the harvested crop
and maybe we can
incrementally improve that improve that
united use efficiency
but the real game changer in that system
i think is actually looking at the food
system as a whole
where less than 10 probably about seven
or eight percent of nitrogen that we had
to fields actually ends up in food that
is consumed
so there are massive um opportunities
there to
improve the system-wide efficiencies in
the food system about getting nutrient
recycling
avoiding emissions as its nutrients are
added to salt and avoiding emissions
from producing them and the second game
changer i think
is going to be coming from freeing up
land through
new technologies that are coming now
with novel foods that decouple
food production from land so for example
renewable energies to feed
electrons to microbes to grow protein or
artificial meats and these kind of
things just
if we can free up land from food
production then we can do a hell of a
lot more with it
i'd like to chime in and um thank you
for bringing in the food system
dominic i think when people talk about
greenhouse gas emissions from food waste
they almost only ever think about
landfills
and thinking about the if something like
30
of food is wasted in the u.s and
similarly in many parts of the world
that's a huge opportunity for increased
efficiency
so i think thinking about trying to
not just find beneficial uses for some
of those waste streams but actually
eliminate the waste streams entirely and
increase that efficiency
as dominic said of nitrogen application
to
you know protein into the actual human
diet
is important and i would also point to
that overall topic as an example where
we do need
systems thinking right so there are
gadgets and widgets and technologies
that need to be improved
but i think there are there is
huge opportunity to improve the way we
manage
systems such as the food system
excellent thank you dominic peter
natalie johannes anything to add or we
move on to the next one
maybe i'll ask i'll keep it going
flipped aside of that
um where do you think that we've already
done enough research
on ghg jhg's and agriculture what should
we treat as settled issues so that we
can focus
on the bigger picture and some of the
emerging game changers that you've
identified
well maybe i'll i'll try something here
um uh
i i i do
think um that we that
we're starting to converge that soil
carbon sequestration is a possibility
and that it has a high potential
whether it can be achieved is a
completely different story
and and what can be achieved and where
the trade-offs are
and and i i think the um
i don't know who mentioned it i'm sure
it's on on dominic's
um mind the trade-offs between n2o
emissions and
and uh and carbon sequestration but
peter also mentioned the
uh trade-offs between um nitrogen
sequestration and phosphorus
sequestration and carbon sequestration
those
those are all important considerations
um
i i do think we are we're slowly
past uh sort of questioning the whole
idea and getting into the weeds of
actually making it happen and and i
think that's a that's a really important
step
um that will then show some of the
the um the weak parts of of uh
actually doing it monitoring it um
verifying it and re and and monetizing
it
which will probably need to happen um
there are countries that are actually
doing it there's
uh always a a sort of um
lingering vernacular that we can never
measure soil carbon
uh we can uh that's impossible and and
while i agree that probably modeling and
practice based
asset assessments of soil carbon uh
changes is is the more practical
approach
there are jurisdictions where they're
actually measuring soil carbon
after the fact and doling out money so
also that can
happen um and and we have not even
really started
um developing the tools in the sort of
the digital agriculture space uh that uh
that we could deploy uh to make this
less a soil sampling and uh dry
combustion analysis approach but
but a much smarter approach so so i
think we're we're already down that road
um uh no i think we don't need to
question the fundamental issues here
um it's really about getting it done and
developing the technology and the market
mechanisms
around it thanks a lot johannes
let me just ask uh one one more question
and then we'll turn it over to the
audience um
you mentioned market mechanisms and
maybe that underpins all of this that if
we don't have a carbon tax or a
nationally based cap and trade maybe
we don't have the appropriate incentives
in place
but um disregarding that from a public
policy perspective and from a private
sector perspective
our current u.s and global priorities um
directly correct with respect to the
real opportunities for mitigating ghgs
and agriculture
do we have right and it's all about
implementation at this point or
what do we need to tell our our friends
and in the political sphere
in terms of what should be priorities
okay i mean i'll try chiming in here
it's a very it's a very difficult
question to answer well because there
are so many different
priorities from different policy makers
and different policies around the world
so giving a generic answer that to that
is
extremely difficult but um i think that
at the moment there seems to be
more prioritization of these simple
incremental changes and really no one
taking a real stab at the systemic
changes to the food system where the big
gains are to be had
so if i had a chance to say so the short
answer is no i don't think
that the prior prioritization is
currently right because they're looking
at incremental improvements
small reductions in net greenhouse gas
explanations from agriculture
and we know that with really large
systemic changes
to how food is made and also to what
people eat
dietary change could can be a massive
influence and tackling some of these
bigger
harder to tackle issues they're actually
where the big gains are to be had
and those are largely missing for the
conversation
thanks a lot dominic in the interest of
time i'm going to turn it over
to the floor now if you have a question
just a mutant ask or
david i think you had a question uh that
that you're writing to me
privately you want to post that publicly
i think it's a very interesting one
okay um i was getting confused finally
what uh
with the what johannes said at the very
end because
when i listened to the other talks
before it seemed to me that
the conclusion would be that the whole
idea of of
agriculture storing co
uh soil organic matter and agriculture
is kind of
a very tiny part of the problem and
probably fairly impossible and it could
easily be undone etc etc so
you know you said at the very end though
johannes you said oh we know what we can
do let's get going and
but i got from the earlier talks that
the money would just cause distortions
and the farmers would
game it and it's not that much anyway
and they're
much much bigger opportunities um
and i've my impression is we should just
forget this whole thing
and go back to the soil health idea
which is fine i mean what peter started
with
explaining all the benefits of of how we
can manage organic matter and
do good things in in yield and and soils
are fine but to say we're part of the
problem part of the solution to ghg
maybe i missed the talk so maybe i
misunderstood you johanna so that's
i was all following along david rule
number one just listen to me
um and then you're all good um
okay um no i'm joking um no i i this is
this is part of the
the the nuance discussion and and i i
really appreciate it because
probably that's that's the impression
that most people
i i probably should should let dominic
and peter talk
um but uh no these are all nuances
around it
um but i i'm i'm putting words in their
mouths now that they would probably not
say we shouldn't
do carbon we shouldn't do put carbon
into the soil
um and we shouldn't use the climate
mechanism to
help that um uh and uh
whether or whether the market mechanisms
can be developed i mean that that's
that's always
the question especially in this country
um but there are other countries who
have already done it and shown that it
works
uh so that's that's just a a us problem
um
but uh i i would say i i
have not seen anything in peter's and
dominic's
talk that i wouldn't agree with um
and yet i still agree with my uh
points as well so we have to get those
together into one
uh yes uh it's a distributed issue um
yes
uh there are trade offs um yes we
probably always need to prioritize soil
health
um and and that's the farmer will always
prioritize that and that's
even now if we drive down soil health
with carbon sequestration
that not only the farmers is uh
not happy about it and will not do it
but also in terms of many other systems
such as biochar it's probably
better to to make energy from biomass
than
than buy a char if if if yields go down
um
because then it's a wash in terms of the
greenhouse gas balance
uh so so i i haven't seen anything that
that is wrong
uh in the statements that were made and
we need to get those
all together in the mix well i wanted it
i'll chime in on this
for just a moment i think
i i think we do have areas of agreement
and to some extent
i think dominic played a very useful
role of of
of being a skeptic and and that's
important because there is
so much hot air around this topic so to
speak
um i think in my mind
one of the challenges is there are
technical
solutions and we can say if you do this
practice in this cropping system
you will increase soil carbon and on
average you will increase yields etc so
there are plenty of technical
improvements to current management that
take a systems approach
to an agronomic system and say look we
get better yields
we get better soil health and we get a
reduced greenhouse gas emissions so
so we need to promote those systems and
make them happen i think a big question
in my mind
is how do you make that happen
and the simple idea in the u.s and
elsewhere of
a payment to an individual farmer for an
individual practice on an individual
field
whether that's in the u.s or or
in bangladesh there are huge problems
with this concept um this is a tragedy
of the commons
and i think the challenge is
managing the land at a bigger scale than
a single field or a portion of a field
etc so some of the issues in measuring
soil carbon
or measuring benefits if we could really
get
farmers in the mississippi river basin
to change
their fertilizer practices and change
soil health practices
at a massive scale it wouldn't be so
hard to measure it
right if we weren't trying to measure it
on every field
we could be doing this from tall towers
and say there's less
co2 emission there's less nitrous oxide
right so i think in my mind that's what
we need to be thinking about is
what are the social and and
political and organizational mechanisms
by which we motivate change
if we can do that at scale then some of
these measurement issues go away
and some of the gaming issues etc go
away
thanks peter very interesting okay can i
chime in on this one as well so thank
you david for bringing that up i was
hoping to stir up a little bit of
controversy and
a discussion around this point so uh
mission accomplished
um yeah i don't think we're in
disagreement um
i i say i don't think anything by talk
said that the soul carbon is a bad thing
it has many mult it has many benefits
for water quality
uh for cropping practices you know cover
crops um are useful
in terms of people farmers are doing
them anyway because they're good in
their crop practices not because they're
trying to store
um fight climate change no-till is
extremely common in dry lands because
farmers want to do it because it helps
them
balance their water budget and improve
yields so there are many reasons for
doing things that store carbon soils
what i've tried to inject some real
caution about though
is having people uh overselling the idea
that this is a silver bullet
which is a lot of excitement around in
the press maybe not in academia as much
but if you look outside
in blogs and papers and things like that
people see saul carmen as being the
answer
that's you know and that maybe gives
people
a thought they're gonna maybe take the
foot off the pedal we've got climate
change sorted we don't need to worry so
much about the other things
and really it can make at best an
incremental
impact although when we see
if we see numbers saying it's it
produces it stores a low carbon
of course in the first few years when
you start practice it stores a lot of
carbon but that doesn't persist
it reaches a new equilibrium and you
need to keep doing that practice forever
and after a decade or a couple of
decades you're not getting any impact on
climate change
so this is why we need to be thinking
about the long-term total potential
rather than the short-term
annual potential and this is where i
think we need to
manage people's expectations not because
cell carbon is a bad thing but
simply because we need to maintain the
sense of urgency about the other things
to do with climate change which are more
impactful and more important in the
climate change
realm well that's why the four per mill
was so intellectually dishonest
because they said that every year you
could keep increasing
at 4 4 per ml and keep on going and
going and going and going and i
maybe i just don't like intellectual
dishonesty of course they've pivoted
quite a bit from that if you go to their
website it's all about soil health which
is fine
and about yields which is fine but
anyway dominic you provoked me so there
you go
we've got to go to another meeting now
so thank you david um we're over time
but i'd like to
entertain one more question if jenny is
still online
hi this is a question for dominic and
johannes so
in dominic you had that blue and uh
orange bar chart and you show that
basically
biomass turned into biochar is basically
equivalent
in terms of its mitigation as bioenergy
just displacing fossil fuels
and so my question is in helping summon
make
and in the context of natalie talking
about how important it is to
keep fossilized carbon fossilized
how do we give the relative value of say
the 100 year biochar sequestration
versus the 1 million year bio
energy displacement so when we're
helping people come up with a decision
tree now of course
this is a yes and question because there
are situations where
you know it's probably more amenable to
making biochar versus bioenergy so i'm
just trying to
understand how can i think about how to
frame it
to a
plus bio energy and when might you
choose bio
energy even if it has a slightly less
total mitigation because it's keeping
that fossilized carbon with a
thousand-year lifespan in the ground
yeah so i had a paper a couple of years
ago 2016 i think published in nature
communications johannes was also a
co-author on that
looking at exactly this question when
might we do
so i compared in fact bioenergy biochar
and bex in the same
thing and it's a very complicated um
decision space because there are so many
factors that might drive you one way or
the other
uh if you're looking at places where
there's very little opportunity to
offset
fossil fuels for example a country that
has already got
or in the future already has a lot of
renewable energy for example
then that's going to push you towards
favoring something that stores carbon
rather than offsets energy
um so the the whole space that it
operates in is quite complicated but
there's still a simple message from it
what it seemed to be is that in our
current world
where our energy systems are quite
carbon intensive
and carbon prices are very low
we would probably prefer to make um most
people would prefer to go the more the
bioenergy route at the moment
now there's a transition once energy
which carbon prices go above about a
hundred dollars per ton of car
co2 sort of three to four hundred
dollars per ton of carbon
and at that point in locations where the
biochar is actually really
helping improve your crop productive
productivity because that's another
review dimensions how does it in fact
impact your soil fertility so in places
where it's actually got a useful benefit
particularly the tropics to soils
there we would introduce more um
more biochar and then there's another
transition some
people sometimes think that if you want
to store more carbon if you want to
improve
the prospects for technology you just
need to throw more money at it
and that's actually not true at all if
you increase the carbon price much
beyond that
other things that were uneconomic at
those carbon prices become the favored
option like
bioenergy for carbon capture and storage
so at higher
very high carbon prices in fact you
would even stop making biochar and
direct all your efforts into these
the tallest bar on that chart yeah i
i agree with that and uh just one one
addition to that um one can also look at
that
um sort of from a geopolitical and
uh dimension of a very very
high uh perspective and say
well there are many many uh ways to
generate energy
um but there is practically only one
viable way to make
organic carbon out of uh co2 that's
photosynthesis
so as as much as we can keeping
co2 in an organic form and creating
value on earth
for humanity is a better way to to do
than
returning it as co2 even if we offset
some other
um non-desirable thing so that's sort of
my more philosophical geopolitical view
on that
why i would if possible always favor
keeping more
more organic carbon on earth
thank you thanks dominic
johannes peter you also want to make a
comment about
uh n in in methane
yes very briefly i just want to say um
because the popular press focuses so
much on carbon
uh it's really important to remember
that in agriculture
greenhouse gas emissions are entirely
dominated by nitrous oxide and methane
and that's totally different from any
other sector so at the global scale
those are are a small part of the issue
but if you're interested in agriculture
and greenhouse gas mitigation in
agriculture
you absolutely have to pay attention to
methane
and nitrous oxide and that's important
because
everything's not always a win-win and of
course carbon and nitrogen are
are stoichiometrically linked in soil
and elsewhere
so you know we're talking about carbon
and nitrogen cycling and and that's
important i think
uh to remember and and in terms of
focusing on
on solutions and avoiding uh problems
disguised as solutions
excellent thank you peter um we are 10
minutes over time now so i think we
should
officially close but i really like to
thank the panel it was fascinating
discussion
and i'm hoping you'll consent to do a
spring follow-on because i suspect
that we could talk about this for a full
day and only start to scratch the
surface
so thank you so much everybody it's a
it's been a delight to have you put the
panel together
and thanks everybody else for attending
see you next week
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu